With DreamWorks' Trolls movie out on Blu-ray
and DVD now, it's time to take a look at some
intriguing deleted scenes that were cut from
the final version of the movie.
Yippee-ki-yay movie lovers, it's Jan here,
and in this video I'm going to review and
explain the scenes from Trolls that we didn't
see in the movie.
Quick warning: there are spoilers here if
you haven't seen the film already, so if you
want to avoid those, tap or click here to
watch my spoiler-free review of the movie.
King Peppy was initially going to hand over
his crown to Princess Poppy much earlier in
the movie and we get an indication of this
in a deleted scene from the beginning of the
film which takes place after the Trolls have
escaped from Bergen Town and Poppy is grown
up.
King Peppy is listening to Poppy tell the
young trolls the story of the trolls and the
Bergens and when she finishes, he asks her
'what happened to the brave King Peppy?'
In this scene we see that Peppy has become
rather absent-minded and confused as he's
grown older; in the final movie they dialled
back that aspect of the character.
And because his memory isn't so good in this
deleted version, he plans to pass on his crown
to Princess Poppy so she can become the new
leader of the trolls.
Also as Poppy's coronation was originally
going to be a much bigger event in the movie,
she was going to need a special coronation
dress.
In fact, the dress was the focus of a cut
scene that would have given more screen time
to The Fashion Twins, Satin and Chenille,
and shown us close up how they were joined
via a loop in their hair.
The scene kicks off with Poppy checking in
on the Fashion Twins to see if her coronation
dress is ready.
As well as giving us a look at the coronation
dress, the deleted sequence also flashes through
a series of extra dresses that Satin and Chenille
have designed for Poppy's big day including
a post-rehearsal gown, formal coronation attire,
an after-coronation party dress, and an after-after
party muumuu dress.
The scene ends with Poppy shouting, "I want
to wear them all!"
The scene was cut as, although it's very entertaining,
the filmmakers felt it was too long and during
test screenings at DreamWorks some people
thought it made Poppy seem spoiled and obnoxious.
By the way, if you're seen my video on the
deleted characters and rejected concepts in
Trolls, you'll know that in one of the movie's
trailers, when the villainous Chef raids the
Troll village, Poppy is dressed in what looks
like a ceremonial gown, however in the final
film, the same scene shows Poppy wearing her
normal clothes.
That's because the party which Poppy was having
at that point in the film was originally going
to be her coronation party rather than just
a celebration party which it was in the final
film.
There was a deleted song called "Bringing
Back Happy" that I was really disappointed
didn't make it into the final movie.
It was going to be a villain song for the
Bergen Chef where we'd see her get deliciously
bad as she sings about how she's bringing
back happiness by cooking up the trolls she's
captured.
It's a fantastic musical number sung by Christine
Baranski who voiced Chef in the movie and
we get to see some of her villainous plans
to mince up the trolls, whip them into a batter
and chop them into sushi.
There's a touch of Hollywood's golden age
of musicals including Carmen Miranda, Esther
Williams and choreographer Busby Berkeley
to the song and the dance routine, and I just
adore it!
It's such a shame it didn't make it into the
movie as villain songs in animations can be
so memorable – for example, I love Ursula's
Poor Unfortunate Souls in The Little Mermaid
and, more recently, Tamatoa's Shiny in Moana.
The filmmakers didn't include the song because
they thought it made the Bergen villain too
appealing and not frightening enough.
Now, what do you think about the deleted scenes
and song and would you like to have seen them
in the movie?
And what's your favourite song by a movie
villain?
Also, would you like to see a Trolls sequel
and what do you think should happen in it?
I'd love to hear your thoughts in the comments
below.
If you enjoyed this, do please like, share
and comment.
And you can check out more of my Trolls and
animation videos by tapping or clicking here.
Thanks for watching and see ya next time.
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers!